[Music]
well Clark County Schools continue to
face a teacher shortage and the
Nationwide shortage is making it
difficult to recruit teachers from
elsewhere as Candace Charles explains
the CCSD School may have a solution and
it could involve your child
good morning class today we're going to
do four corners this is not the first
time Alfonso sociedo has led a classroom
discussion thanks to Southeast Career
Technical Academy he's well versed in it
I want to make a kid feel empowered and
enlightened he's part of a solution to
the ongoing teacher shortage I feel like
I'm meeting and he is teacher Sean Stein
says the program offers the opportunity
to look within that's how we take these
schools and improve entire neighborhoods
Zion has been molding the teachers of
tomorrow for six years now and he's
already starting to see the fruits of
that labor by the time they're 21
they're going to already have been
exposed to the ins and outs the highs
and lows of education for seven eight
years gaining both college credit and
the in-classroom experience some
teachers say is needed to combat the
common five-year burnout that looks like
a fight so you have the hat and then you
have the bump
in your gear for Lily Rose Bingham now
taking what she's learned the last four
years inside the classroom that gives us
kind of the real experience we need to
know if we want to continue with the
profession so we're not having teachers
that are going in and like hating their
jobs we want to be there we want to do
it because we know that it's needed
although there are still concerns about
pay these future teachers know they will
pave the way for our youth Candace
Charles 8 News Now
well the academy takes 500 freshmen each
year but spots do fill up fast you must
apply online and students will be
selected at the beginning of next month